weniger exporte und mehr arbeitslose die
deutsche wirtschaft steht vor einer
schweren rezession sagen die
wirtschaftsweisen die wir hier nicht
sehen gerade was ist ungarn
aber ich denke jetzt machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten überblick hoffe ich
doch dass ist jetzt was ganz anderes
also geht einiges durcheinander es geht
in der sendung auch um die lage in
wolfsburg die sich zuspitzt und um die
macht per dekret das sehen wir hier das
ungarische parlament der
ministerpräsident regiert jetzt noch
unbestimmte zeit ohne kontrolle durchs
parlament
guten abend meine damen und herren ein
etwas ungewöhnlicher anfang wir bitten
diese technischen probleme zu
entschuldigen eine neue woche in
schweren zeiten wir haben für sie auch
heute den überblick über diesen
nachrichten montag
und wir beginnen heute mit dem r wort
rezession eine tiefe schwere rezession
das ist die erwartung der
wirtschaftsforscher sowohl für die
deutsche wirtschaft als auch für europa
insgesamt
der sachverständigenrat in deutschland
sagt voraus dass die wirtschaft in
diesem jahr deutlich schrumpfen werde
und nach einer umfrage wird es in
deutschlands industrie drastisch mehr
kurzarbeit geben details jetzt von
christiane hübscher längst hat corona
auch die wirtschaft angesteckt wie ich
dass der einbruch wird das haben die
sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen versucht
voraus zu berechnen
im besten fall folgen in einer v kurve
auf fünf wochen wirtschaftlichen
stillstand noch drei wochen
erholungsphase das bruttoinlandsprodukt
würde in diesem fall um 2,8 prozent
sinken und im schlimmsten angenommenen
fall hier die blaue kurve steht die
wirtschaft ganze sieben wochen still und
muss ich noch fünf wochen erholen
das würde ein minus von 5,4 prozent aufs
jahr bedeuten
so beschreiben es die wirtschaftsweisen
in einer video konferenz in dem tiefen v
was unser risikoszenario ist das schlägt
rein wir haben allerdings noch mv die
annahme dass wir nach ende der maßnahmen
an
im zweiten halbjahr gegen ende im
vierten quartal auch wieder schnell die
produktion steigern können also in jedem
fall eine kräftige rezession aber nicht
so schlimm wie in der finanzkrise 2009
was die wirtschaftsweisen noch vorher
sagen es könnte etwa 125.000 mehr
arbeitslose geben
die löhne werden geringer steigen und
die verbraucher etwas weniger
konsumieren
der export wird zurückgehen um mehr als
vier prozent nur die baubranche boomt
weiter mit einem angenommenen
wachstumsplus von 2,7 prozent ist damit
zu rechnen dass die kommunalfinanzen
sehr stark von der krise gezeichnet sein
werden
die einnahmen werden stark einbrechen
einmal auf guter konjunktur aber dann
auch aufgrund der maßnahmen
steuerstundung und so weiter und ich
glaube dass die politik da noch mal
nachsteuern könnte außerdem müsse die
bundesregierung schon jetzt über
kriterien für den exit nachdenken und
schon mal ein konjunkturpaket für danach
einen planen raten die wirtschaftsweisen
so wir haben gesehen wie die ausblicke
für die wirtschaft sind die
bundesregierung will gegensteuern mit
einem historisch beispiellosen
milliarden programm insgesamt mehrere
hundert milliarden ab heute können auch
die ersten kleinunternehmer anträge
stellen und jetzt muss sich zeigen ob es
tatsächlich so schnell und
unbürokratisch läuft wie versprochen
oliver drücker berichtet modewelt roth
in pattensen bei hannover mit seiner
frau und einer mitarbeiterin betreibt
wolfgang roth die boutique doch jetzt
fehlen die einnahme ist bleiben aber
ladenmiete gehälter und die
eingetroffene ware muss bezahlt werden
wert 20.000 euro wir haben ein
saisongeschäft frühjahr sommer und
herbst winter und wenn wir hier mal auf
die ware gucken diese dieser bereich
jacken frühjahrs jacken und frühjahrs
hosen hat einen ablauftermin wettermäßig
bedingt ich sag jetzt mal mai und wenn
wir bis mein ich wieder auf haben dann
kriegen wir ein echtes problem wie viele
andere will roth jetzt zuschüsse aus dem
50 milliarden schweren corona
soforthilfeprogramm des bundes für
kleinstunternehmen anfragen auf bis zu
9000 euro hätte er bei seiner
betriebsgröße anspruch
zusätzlich beantragte er schon zuschüsse
aus dem corona hilfsprogramm des landes
niedersachsen da bekommt der 3000 euro
ein guter anfang aber auf dauer zu wenig
kritisieren die unternehmerverbände
niedersachsen das geld reicht natürlich
nicht wir werden wenn wir nicht weitere
programme auflegen
innerhalb der nächsten sechs bis acht
wochen die ersten blüten erleben müssen
auch an die wirtschaft denken wenn die
wirtschaft nicht läuft kriegen die
menschen noch ganz andere probleme
trotzdem ist rot dankbar über die
zuschüsse damit hätte er nicht gerechnet
uns wird wirklich geholfen damit
existenzbedrohend und uns hilft was der
stadt wenn man muss mit dem staat nicht
einverstanden mit der regierung
aber was sie im augenblick in den
letzten zehn tagen gemacht haben ist für
uns super
ob die zuschüsse reichen oder nur ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein sein werden
hängt davon ab wie lange sein geschäft
geschlossen bleibt
unser nächstes thema in dieser krise
erst hieß es in deutschland mundschutz
für alle ist eher unnötig jetzt läuft
die diskussion doch in eine andere
richtung wenn alle schutzmasken tragen
in der öffentlichkeit dann singt
zumindest das risiko andere anzustecken
und das hilft dann ja auch jedem wieder
selbst doch das problem bleibt bei uns
gibt es nicht genug masken unser nachbar
österreich geht derweil einen schritt
weiter und führt einem mundschutz
pflicht ein david sauer berichtet
österreichs kanzler kurz zieht die zügel
an
überall wo viele menschen aufeinander
treffen gilt in österreich bald masken
pflicht los geht diese woche schon in
supermärkten
das soll die ansteckungszahlen endlich
senken helfen durch das tragen der maske
kann man andere menschen schützen indem
man sie nicht an niesen husten kann und
die übertragung durch die luft etwas
reduziert doch der markt für mundschutze
ist so gut wie leer gefegt das ist
leider derzeit schwierig das am
weltmarkt in großen stückzahlen
bestellen zu können
vor allem für den professionellen
gebrauch vieles ist vergriffen ein
riesenproblem denn ohne anständige
hygiene keine behandlung im interesse
von personal und patienten
die nachlieferung von masken passiert
nicht weder in kliniken noch in praxen
geschweige denn ein pflegeheim oder
feuerwehr polizei die brauchen ja auch
mal masken in deutschland werden kaum
massen produziert die allermeisten
kommen aus china
und dort gibt es aktuell wie eigentlich
überall besonders großen bedarf so
werden masken vom cent artikel zum
luxusgut um kliniken besser zu versorgen
versucht die bundesregierung den ankauf
zu beschleunigen und will lieferverträge
ohne verhandlungen über den preis
ermöglichen
doch die verteilung laufe nicht
reibungslos klagen ärzte die knappheit
die können sie nicht abschaffen aber
wenn dann firmen daran die sagen ich
mache es dann könnten sie besser
unterstützen und bei der verteilung
vielleicht besser helfen damit der
private bedarf die klinik versorgung
nicht zusätzlich gefährdet nehmen viele
menschen masken selber vorlagen dafür
gibt es zum beispiel online
lange hieß es diese masken würden kaum
schützen inzwischen aber sagen auch
fachleute je mehr mitmachen desto besser
wenn man in der öffentlichkeit sich
bewegt vielleicht selber das virus in
sich trägt und sorgt mit einer selbst
gebastelten maske dafür dass die
tröpfchen die man beim husten niesen
vielleicht auch beim sprechen in die
umwelt abgeben würde das die
zurückgehalten werden und für diesen
fall ist auch eine selbst gebastelte
maske besser als gar keine maske auch do
it yourself kann also andere schützen
helfen dennoch bleibt es nur eine
ergänzung zu den sonstigen
hygienemaßnahmen und kein ersatz für den
wirklich gesunden sicherheitsabstand ein
ganzes land guckt gebannt auf die
aktuellen zahlen dieser pandemie weil
damit ganz unmittelbar die frage
verbunden ist wie geht es weiter
wie lange werden die einschränkungen des
täglichen lebens noch gebraucht und was
muss passieren damit sie aufgehoben
werden können
informationen dazu von julia schröter es
war eine woche wie deutschland sie noch
nie erlebt hat seit sieben tagen beinahe
stillstand tiefe einschnitte ins normale
leben um das virus zu stoppen aber
gelingt das auch die aktuellen zahlen
laut johns hopkins universität gibt es
in deutschland 63 1929 infizierte 560
menschen starben
auch mit der kontaktsperre die zahl der
korona
alle steigt weiter deutlich dass es
keine schnellen erfolge gibt für
virologen nicht überraschend ja das
dauert leider so lange und es hat ja
auch niemand versprochen dass das nach
einer woche vorbei sein wird das muss
man auch mal ganz klar sagen wir haben
immer gesagt wir sind am anfang eine
wichtige größe für experten ist der
zeitraum in dem sich fallzahlen
verdoppeln im moment ist dass in
deutschland etwa alle sechs tage der
fall
ziel der bundesregierung ist es die zeit
bis zur verdopplung auf zehn oder noch
mehr tage zu strecken
das hieße weiter ein anstieg aber
langsamer und wenn wir diese verdopplung
in 14 tage haben oder eben in 21 tagen
dann ist das ein niveau wo wir
letztendlich auch den anstieg besser
abfedern können mit unserem
gesundheitssystem lockerungen kämen viel
zu früh so sehen ist die entscheider in
bund und ländern
die lage ist weiter sehr sehr ernst
deswegen gibt es keinen anlass in
deutschland oder in bayern darüber zu
reden dass es entwarnung gebe es gibt
keinen anlass falsche hoffnungen zu
wecken und es ist keine zeit für einen
vorschnellen exit oder entsprechende
debatten in bayern und anderen
bundesländern wurden die ausgangs
beschränkungen bis zum ende der
osterferien verlängert so plant ist auch
die bundesregierung stand jetzt
zumindest das corona virus trifft die
stadt wolfsburg besonders hart in einem
pflegeheim dort sind 17 menschen
gestorben
und jetzt sieht sich das klinikum in
wolfsburg gezwungen keine neuen
patienten mehr aufzunehmen
das gibt es sonst bisher nirgends in
deutschland die situation dort ist
schwierig und hat das land niedersachsen
dazu gebracht für alle pflegeheime
anzuordnen erstmal keine neuen bewohner
mehr
fabian köhler berichtet sie kommen zum
abtransportieren der toten 17
demenzkranke senioren sind hier im
wolfsburger hans lilie pflegeheim in
folge der kogit 19 erkrankung gestorben
von 165 bewohnern sind inzwischen stand
heute 79 weitere mit dem corona virus
infiziert die verschärfung der lage
zwingt niedersachsens
gesundheitsministerin zum handeln ab
sofort verhänge ich einen aufnahmestopp
für neue bewohnerinnen und bewohner in
pflegeheimen
es sei denn die einrichtung kann eine
strikte quarantäne
eine strikte zweiwöchige quarantäne
gewährleisten neuaufnahmen sind nur in
singulären kurzzeitpflege einrichtungen
oder rehaeinrichtungen möglich die wir
für diese funktion herrichten
innerhalb weniger tage ist wolfsburg in
den fokus gerückt auch im klinikum der
stadt haben sich mindestens 14
mitarbeiter mit dem corona virus
infiziert das krankenhaus greift zu
drastischen maßnahmen nimmt vorerst
keine neuen patienten mehr auf sind
aufgefordert werde nirgendwo wirklich
nicht das wenig um auch versuchen das
klinikum ist von außen für besucher für
ambulante patienten die aus bestimmten
gründen noch der mine telekom hatten
nicht mehr zugänglich um zusätzliche
krankenhaus plätze zu schaffen müssen
jetzt 22 reha kliniken in niedersachsen
patienten ohne corona infektion
aufnehmen denn wir brauchen genau diese
zusätzliche kapazitäten damit wir aus
reichlich keiten für patientinnen und
patienten haben die unter anderen
erkrankungen leiden im wolfsburger
klinikum werden jetzt alle patienten und
das gesamte personal auf cupid 19
getestet wann der betrieb wieder normal
laufen kann ist derzeit vollkommen offen
ja eine ganz schwierige situation haben
wir in den letzten tagen ja bereits
geschildert wir gehen jetzt live small
in ihlow in wolfsburg malen genannt wie
sieht denn der plan in wolfsburg jetzt
aus um die versorgung der kranken und
die pflege der bedürftigen zu sichern
also erstmal steht wolfsburg unter
schock die stadt ist im krisenmodus mit
dieser corona infektionswelle 14
mitarbeiter hier im städtischen klinikum
positiv getestet und es ist noch nicht
klar ob sie patienten angesteckt haben
erstmal wird hier rigoros getestet es
soll weitere testergebnisse die soll es
in der nacht geben die patienten sind in
einzelzimmern untergebracht und müssen
die ganze zeit immunschutz tragen und es
gibt einen aufnahmestopp neue patienten
ausgenommen ist natürlich der kreißsaal
und die notaufnahme sie stehen vor dem
krankenhaus in wolfsburg wie wichtig ist
denn das krank
für die versorgung der stadt ja das ist
nicht irgendein krankenhaus das ist ein
großes krankenhaus ein städtisches
krankenhaus mit mehr als 2000
beschäftigten da ist die sorge natürlich
groß unter krankenhausmitarbeitern aber
auch unter patienten und deswegen auch
der griff zu diesem drastischen
maßnahmen also so ein aufnahmestopp
neuen patienten das ist ein novum in
deutschland das hat es noch nicht
gegeben
wir drücken den nachrichten aus
wolfsburg moll und herzlichen dank und
damit in dieser sendung ins ausland im
kampf gegen die pandemie geht ungarn
sehr umstrittene wege das parlament in
budapest hat jetzt ein notstandsgesetz
beschlossen es gibt der rechtsnationalen
regierung von ministerpräsident viktor
orban weitgehend freie hand sie kann auf
unbegrenzte zeit mit verordnungen
regieren ohne parlamentarische kontrolle
massive kritik kommt von der opposition
wolf christian ullrich berichtet das
militär patrouilliert jetzt auf den
straßen von budapest die botschaft die
regierung zeigt stärke gegen das corona
virus darüber hinaus hat das ungarische
parlament heute ein notstandsgesetz
beschlossen mit vollmachten die der
regierung aber noch größere macht
verleihen als sie ohnehin schon hat und
die opposition ist entsetzt
das notstandsgesetz ermöglicht der
regierung für unbegrenzte zeit einfach
geltendes recht außer acht zu lassen
ministerpräsident orban kann jetzt auf
unbestimmte zeit am parlament vorbei
regieren
orbáns fidesz blog hat mit seiner
zweidrittelmehrheit außerdem beschlossen
dass es vorerst keine wahlen gibt bis zu
acht jahre haft bei verstößen gegen
quarantäne bis zu fünf jahre haft bei
verbreitung von falschmeldungen über die
korona krise
damit hätte die regierung
sanktionsmittel gegen kritische berichte
ich in der bekanntlich jedes land
versucht gegen das virus seine eigenen
maßnahmen nach eigenen maßstäben zu
finden sagt der regierungssprecher dazu
im home office und das tut auch in gang
opern inszeniert sich derweil als
krisenmanager nimmt
öffentlichkeitswirksam eine chinesische
lieferung von hilfsgütern entgegen die
neuen notstandsmaßnahmen werden seine
macht weiter zementieren und ihn
zusätzlich als starken mann in szene
setzen
das alles soll im übrigen auch
kaschieren wie desolat die lage im
gesundheitswesen ist sagt er ungern
beobachter paul lendvai die spitäler
sind in einem schrecklichen zustand
dieser europa regierung hat er fußball
stadien gebaut statt spitäler zu
modernisieren zu hause lässt die
regierung plakatieren das
notstandsgesetz das corona bekämpfen
soll bringt ungarns demokratie weiter in
die krise und dann italien und die usa
das sind die länder mit den weltweit
meisten cola infektionen
gerade für amerika rechnen experten mit
einem weiter starken anstieg die rede
ist von über 100.000 möglichen toten und
millionen infektionen gucken wir uns die
zahlen genauer an in den usa gibt es
bislang etwa 150.000 registrierte corona
fälle das heißt im moment ist mindestens
jeder 2002 infiziert zum vergleich
italien mit rund 100.000 fällen hier hat
sich jeder sechshundertste angesteckt in
den usa wurde allerdings bisher nicht
annähernd so viel getestet wie anderswo
lange hatte die regierung die lage
verharmlost ines trams die comfortline
ein lazarettschiff der us-marine es soll
als extra krankenhaus dienen in new york
city dem epizentrum der korona krise in
den usa die bestehenden stationen
überfüllt pfleger und ärzte sprechen von
einer kriegszone
für die sie ohne genügend masken und
schutzkleidung nicht gewappnet sein
wir haben auch angst wir kämpfen auch um
unser leben sie versuchen den kopf über
wasser zu halten nicht unterzugehen
präsident trump macht derweil angesichts
rasant steigender infizierten zahlen
eine kehrtwende an ostern so hatte er
versprochen würden die kirchen voll sein
werde amerika zu normalem leben
zurückkehren nun verlängert er die
einschränkungen bis ende april
es war nur eine erwartung ich habe nicht
postern gesagt sondern es wäre großartig
wenn wir es bis ostern schaffen könnten
nun erwarten wir da aber den höhepunkt
der krise
danach werden die zahlen hoffentlich
runtergehen improvisierte bedingungen in
new yorker kliniken die rufe von hier
nach besserer ausstattung will vom nicht
hören
indirekt klagt er das
krankenhauspersonal an sie würden
schutzausrüstung wie gesichtsmasken
stehlen
der präsident sollte unsere
krankenhausmitarbeiter lobin statt ihnen
etwas zu unterstellen das ist taktlos
nicht hilfreich
er ist der oberste befehlshaber und
sollte uns die unterstützung schicken
die wir brauchen sonst sollte er gar
nichts denken es sind unklare signale
die weiterhin aus dem weißen haus kommen
bislang haben sie das krisen-management
im land behindert
lange hatte man den eindruck die korona
pandemie ist im größten land der welt
kein großes thema
doch auch die behörden in russland
verschärfen jetzt die regeln für die
bevölkerung erst hat der präsident
wladimir putin diese woche landesweit
als arbeitsfrei erklärt dann wurden
reisewege ins ausland gekappt und jetzt
gilt in der hauptstadt eine strenge
ausgangssperre in moskau ist für uns
christian sam nun also auch in moskau
leer gefegten straßen heute morgen ruhe
statt rush hour
gestern abend kamen die mitteilung des
moskauer bürgermeisters sowie an ihn
ausgangssperre nun auch zum einkaufen um
die ecke mit sicherheitsabstand im
supermarkt oder zum gassi gehen und müll
rausbringen darf man noch vor die tür
die menschen machen sich jetzt gedanken
über ihre gesundheit und die ihrer
angehörigen
es ist sehr wichtig zu hause zu bleiben
bereits am wochenende war moskaus
zentrum leergefegt alles geschlossen
präsident putin hatte die russen
aufgefordert in dieser woche nicht
arbeiten zu gehen
zu hause zu bleiben doch viele freuten
sich über die putin führen
11 corona tote gibt es in russland und
immer mehr infizierte 1836 sind es
aktuell die offiziellen zahlen sind
niedrig verglichen mit dem rest der welt
bislang wurden in russland 343.000
corona tests durchgeführt war mehr als
140 millionen einwohnern zweifel auch
wie stark das russische
gesundheitssystem ist wenn die zahl der
korona kranken steigt bei der
oppositionsnahen gewerkschaft allianz
der ärzte erzählen sie von anrufen
verzweifelter mediziner in vielen
krankenhäusern in der provinz gibt es
weder genug geräte geschweige denn
schutz für die mitarbeiter man kann nur
hoffen und beten
das ist bei uns nicht so wird wie in
italien oder anderen ländern
die botschaft der regierung alles unter
kontrolle
im krankenhaus in der stadt jaroslawl
haben sie gerade eine spende eines
unternehmers bekommen rund 1000 euro für
masken und desinfektionsmittel damit sie
hier weiter ihren job machen können
bei aller unsicherheit in der korona
krise ein datum steht seit heute fest
die olympischen sommerspiele in tokio
mussten jahr verschoben werden
sie sollen jetzt am 23 juli 2021
beginnen
viel zeit also für vorfreude diese frage
wäre beantwortet viele andere bleiben
noch offen auch heute senden wir wieder
ein zdf spezial um 19.30 bekommen sie
von marcus niehaves antworten auf ihre
fragen zur corona krise und mit unserer
zdf heute app halten wir sie natürlich
jederzeit auf dem laufenden
beispielsweise mit einem corona update
jeden abend noch zwei weitere meldungen
heute die nato hat ein neues mitglied
nord mazedonien das land auf dem
westbalkan ist der dreißigste nato staat
wie jetzt auch die 30 flaggen vor
im hauptquartier in brüssel zeigen
möglich wurde der beitrag erst durch die
namensänderung im letzten jahr von
mazedonien zu nord mazedonien
jahrzehntelang hatte das land mit seinen
nachbarn griechenland wegen der
gleichnamigen region dort gestritten
als nächstes will nord mazedonien in die
eu eintreten und dann schauen wir noch
auf die wichtigsten ergebnisse der
bayerischen kommunalwahlen weil der
stichwahl in der zweiten runde ging die
stimmabgabe ja nur per briefwahl
jetzt ist ausgezählt in münchen gab es
einen klaren sieg von spd amtsinhaber
dieter reiter die spd gewinnt auch in
ingolstadt und in bamberg verliert aber
ihre traditionelle hochburg nürnberg an
die csu die uhren stehen auf sommerzeit
das wetter noch nicht der winter hat
sich in vielen ecken deutschlands noch
mal blicken lassen weiße strände
temperaturen unter null zum beispiel in
ueckermünde am stettiner haff
anscheinend nicht dass wunsch wetter der
spaziergänger gefischt wurde aber
trotzdem verschneite autos nasse straßen
auch in hamburg für den weg zur arbeit
brauchten viele mehr zeit aber lange
kann das jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr so
gehen zeigen diese bilder wie es
weitergeht dazu mehr gleich von westen
terry
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit
der kollegin marietta slomka um 21 uhr
45 sie hat fragen an den obersten
wirtschaftsweisen zur drohenden
rezession jetzt gleich wie gesagt ein
zdf spezial morgen sind wir wieder für
sie da um 7 versprochen wo immer es geht
in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tonangebend ist
immer noch das risiko hoch vor island
aber es wird allmählich schwächer und
verabschiedet sich nach westen hin
kalte luft kommt immer noch aus dem
norden zu uns wird aber auch allmählich
wärmer nur am freitag noch einmal
kühlluft und zum wochenende dann
deutliche erwärmung aus dem südwesten
schauen wir nachts im norden und im
süden gibt es nur wenige wolken in der
mitte schneit es etwas und hier bildet
sich eine schneedecke in den
mittelgebirgen aus und da kann es
durchaus glatt während temperaturen null
grad richtung westen hin und -3 grad im
osten am kältesten ist es im süden mit
minus 10 grad direkt an den alpen
morgen scheint die sonne besonders
häufig zwischen dem emsland und der
nordsee und im südwesten
im osten ist es deutlich bewirkte aber
insgesamt ist es trocken mit
temperaturen zwischen null grad im
vogtland und 11 grad im südwesten dass
es die temperaturspanne in deutschland
morgen und in den nächsten tagen am
mittwoch wird es ziemlich sonnig werden
vor allem in der südhälfte nach norden
etwas regen sechs bis zwölf grad am
donnerstag ist es deutlich ruhiger und
trocken bis 15 und freitag kommt etwas
kühlere luft im norden an damit ein
schöner abend